das sogenannte islamische emirat
wer sind die neuen herrscher und was
haben sie mit afghanistan vor von der
hauptstadt kabul machen wir uns auf
richtung süden
wir können uns im land frei bewegen mit
erlaubnis der taliban
sie wollen uns zeigen wie sicher das
land heute ist
21 jahre nach ihrem sturz sind die
taliban wieder an der macht der ziel
afghanistan befrieden um einen mächtigen
islamischen gottesstaat am hindukusch zu
bilden
doch längst nicht alle afghanen stehen
hinter ihnen es gibt unterschiedliche
gruppen auch ein ableger des islamischen
staats hat viele kämpfer im land seit
wochen kommt es immer wieder zu schweren
gefechten
diese aufnahmen aus der hauptstadt kabul
zeigen einen achtstündigen schusswechsel
der taliban mit dem die es
auch das alltag im emirat immer wieder
anschläge mit vielen toten
die taliban versuchen afghanistan heute
als modernen staat zu führen doch an den
grundüberzeugungen hat sich seit den
90er jahren nichts geändert
islamistische ideologie statt meinungs-
und pressefreiheit
vollverschleierung stadt frauen richten
wir sind unterwegs auf dem
er verbindet die hauptstadt kabul mit
kandahar und ist die wichtigste
handelsroute des landes
mit westlichen geldern ausgebaut wurde
der highway für die taliban zum symbol
der besatzung
20 jahre lang war dass die gefährlichste
straße der welt was täglich gab es
anschläge entführungen und überfällen
hauptsächlich von den taliban die
afghanen nannten diese straße autobahn
des todes die taliban versprechen uns
dass wir heute hier sicher sind ganz
wohl fühlen wir uns trotzdem nicht
am straßenrand ein dorf das immer noch
komplett zerstört ist
jahrelang wüteten hier schwere kämpfe
der dorfälteste erklärt dass sich die
taliban hier verschanzt und das dorf als
versteck für ihre angriffe auf die
strasse genutzt hätten
[Musik]
die regierung hat uns reingelegt
sie haben uns eigentlich versprochen
hier im dorf stellungen aufzubauen und
auch dort drüben auf dem hügel
es gab hier gefechte aber für unsere
sicherheit haben sie nicht gesorgt
für den wiederaufbau fehlt das geld
dörfer wie dieses sehen wir immer wieder
entlang des highways
in der provinzhauptstadt rassen haben
die taliban die zerschossenen fahrzeuge
von der autobahn wie trophäen am
straßenrand aufgestellt
sie sind stolz auf den sieg über die
internationalen truppen
im amt für information und kultur werden
wir vom chef empfangen habibullah
mudschahed ist ein taliban der ersten
stunde 28 jahre hat er für seinen traum
vom emirat gekämpft jetzt ist er in der
provinz ghasni der oberste medienchef
die atmosphäre ist frostig doch man sagt
uns wir dürften alle fragen stellen wir
wollen wissen wie er die vielen opfer
von damals entlang der autobahn
rechtfertigt
das hat die zerstörungen die sie entlang
der straße gesehen haben sind durch
unsere bomben herbeigeführt worden wir
haben amerikanische fahrzeuge
angegriffen und zerstört aber das war
nötig denn damit wurde auch die
hauptursache für korruption zerstören
das islamische emirat wird alle straßen
und autobahnen repariert
habibullah mudschahed will dass die
afghanen ihre geschicke in die eigenen
hände nehmen und weder moralisch noch
wirtschaftlich abhängig sind von fremden
mächten
er will uns zeigen wie modern die
taliban im jahr 2022 sind und nimmt uns
mit in sein medienzentrum
vor 20 jahren hatten die taliban alle
medien verboten jetzt nutzen sie sie
bereitwillig sie haben erkannt dass eine
staatlich gelenkte propaganda viele
vorteile hat
radio taliban ist schon eher
die medien sind sehr wichtig für uns
bevor wir an die macht kamen hatten wir
schon einige radioprogramme aber jetzt
stellen wir überall antennen auf vor
allem auf den bergen um unser programm
zu übertragen
das radio ist für uns sehr wichtig weil
es das handeln der regierung für alle
richtig einordnet die arbeiten hier
sogar an einer internationalen
übertragung
ein kameramann des hauseigenen senders
filmt unseren besuchern jeder soll sehen
dass sich das deutsche fernsehen für die
arbeit der taliban interessiert
im fernsehstudio sind die
renovierungsarbeiten in vollem gang
bald soll auch hier das
regierungsprogramm im tv und auf youtube
verbreitet werden noch sind die
redaktionsräume nicht fertig doch man
merkt habibullah mudschahed an dass er
das projekt taliban 2.0 mit aller macht
nach vorne treiben will
was die scheinbar nicht nach vorne
treiben wollen bis die bildung von
mädchen wir sind in einer untergrund
schule irgendwo in afghanistan
mädchen gemeinsam mit jungen mädchen die
längst keine schule mehr besuchen
durften
[Applaus]
die
mädchen und frauen im ganzen land sind
frustriert dass man ihnen die chance auf
bildung nehmen will die schüler und ihre
familien hier sind in großer gefahr die
strafen der taliban sind oft drakonisch
die 17-jährige sache nicht unbedingt
ärztin werden
sie erlauben jungen bis zur zwölften
klasse die schule zu besuchen
warum dürfen wir unsere schule nicht
fertig machen
was ist der unterschied zwischen mädchen
und jungen sind wir nicht gewürdigt
dafür
da haben wir nicht das recht eine gute
ausbildung zu bekommen jungen haben
immer so viel glück und wir nur unglück
sagt ina ist selbst erst 17 bis vor
kurzem ging sie noch zur schule jetzt
ist sie lehrerin und hat alles aus dem
nichts aufgebaut ein klassenraum für 50
schülerinnen und schüler bücher
organisiert einen lehrplan erstellt sie
selbst macht das alles freiwillig
verdient kein geld
ich will noch mehr lernen um unser land
aufzubauen ich will unser land nicht so
sehen
unsere väter haben keine arbeit
diese situation ist so schwierig für uns
aber
ich werde nicht aufgeben ich werde
weiter unterrichten
china wollte eigentlich architektin
werden jetzt unterrichtet sie jeden tag
sechs stunden ihr bruder hat sie dazu
ermutigt den kindern englisch
beizubringen
lernen das ist den schülerinnen und
schülern enorm wichtig
[Musik]
alle wollen hier englisch lernen um ins
ausland zu gehen
danach wollen sie wieder zurückkommen
nach afghanistan um unser land in
frieden wieder aufzubauen
raus aus afghanistan
seit die taliban vor einem jahr die
macht übernahmen haben die
internationalen truppen rund 300.000
afghanen ausgeflogen
[Musik]
doch noch viel mehr haben afghanistan
auf dem landweg über iran und pakistan
verlassen der konten egal wer diese
chance nicht hatte auf gefährlicheren
wegen
asif mohsini will seine heimat so
schnell wie möglich verlassen und
verkauft seine letzten habseligkeiten um
sich einen schlepper über die grenze
leisten zu können
die verhandlungen laufen nicht gut der
händler erkennt dass asif mohsini seine
sachen unbedingt loswerden muss so
schnell wie möglich
wir konnten uns nicht auf einen preis
einigen
er wollte mir sehr wenig geld geben aber
ich verkaufe meine sachen nicht so
billig ich muss nach einem anderen
käufer suchen
währenddessen versucht as&s ehefrau
nafisa zu hause den kühlschrank zu
verkaufen
vieles in der wohnung ist schon weg
doch sie brauchen noch 90.000 afghani
umgerechnet knapp 1000 euro für die
flucht
[Musik]
heute hat die familie kein glück
die zwei frauen wollen nicht zahlen was
nach pfizer gerne bekommen hätte
die wirtschaftliche lage im land ist
katastrophal die menschen achten genau
darauf wofür sie ihr geld ausgeben
alles ist so teuer sogar reis und öl das
ist ein neugeborenes baby und ich kann
mir nicht mal milchpulver leisten
auch sohn ali hat seinen job auf dem
markt verloren ist arbeitslos
baby fatima ist krank doch für
medikamente hat die familie kein geld
vater asse war kraftfahrer für eine
spanische hilfsorganisation
er hat gut verdient
doch als die taliban an die macht kamen
haben die spanier das land verlassen und
sf seinen job verloren ein jahr ist er
jetzt arbeitslos und die familie in
höchster not tee und brot ist alles was
sie sich im moment leisten können sf ist
es wichtig dass wir seine geschichte
erzählen wir sollen sehen wie groß das
leid im land ist
wir haben angst vor den gefahren wenn
wir die iranische grenze illegal
überqueren
aber die angst noch schlimmere tage hier
zu erleben ist größer als meine sorge
der druck ist unglaublich groß
vielleicht werden wir getötet oder von
der iranischen polizei aufgegriffen und
wieder abgeschoben
aber das ist alles nicht so schlimm wie
das leben hier
jeden tag läuft asse von händler zu
händler
die familie ist verzweifelt und sieht
keinen anderen ausweg als ihre heimat zu
verlassen
wer sich mit dem taliban-regime
arrangieren kann bleibt sowie phase
lachmann mosley auch wenn er nicht alle
überzeugungen der taliban teilt der
familienvater war einst eine moderne den
kommandeur im bürgerkrieg anfang der
90er jahre
ihm unterstanden 2000 männer jetzt fährt
er seine beiden jüngsten töchter zur
schule
ja für mich ist es sehr wichtig dass sie
zur schule gehen weil sie die zukunft
von afghanistan sind und das land vor
der dunkelheit retten müssen
ich will dass meine töchter ärztinnen
werden und ihrem land dienen in regionen
wie taktierer und frost haben wir
nämlich keine weiblichen doktoren
der ehemalige kämpfer hätte vor jahren
beinahe eine seiner drei frauen verloren
konservative afghanen erlauben ihren
frauen normalerweise nicht sich von
männern behandeln zu lassen
das war für phase lacht man das
ausschlaggebende ereignis seinen
töchtern eine höhere bildung zu
ermöglichen
die beiden jüngsten gehen jetzt auf eine
privatschule
normale afghanen können sich das nicht
leisten
mir wurde die möglichkeit zur schule zu
gehen genommen ich war nicht in der
schule obwohl ich das immer wollte ich
hatte keine schuhe kein geld keine
stifte und keine bücher bei vielen
meiner freunde war das anders sie
konnten zur schule gehen aber ich nicht
in der schule fällt auf dass in den
klassen nicht mehr viele mädchen sitzen
und setzt die müssen wenn es nach den
taliban geht in ein paar jahren zu hause
bleiben
das gilt auch für die töchter von
fachmann
der hat insgesamt sieben töchter doch
mit der kamera sehen wir auch zu hause
nur die zwei houston zwei seiner älteren
töchter arbeiten zwar schon im
krankenhaus
doch filmen dürfen wir sie nicht weder
zu hause noch bei der arbeit ich durfte
alleine mit ihnen sprechen als die
kameras aus waren männer waren dabei
schafft man ist ein konservativer
paschtunen die taliban sagt er neben
afghanistan die unabhängigkeit wieder
zurück die amerikaner seien besatzer
gewesen
wir danken gott für die jetzige
situation
die hatten 43 jahre krieg jeden tag
wurde gekämpft aber das letzte jahr
unter den taliban war friedlich jetzt
haben wir keinen krieg mehr in ganz
afghanistan
überall ist es sicher
phase rachman ist tief gläubig und
richtet sein gesamtes leben nach dem
koran die internationale gemeinschaft
solle das islamische emirat afghanistan
anerkennen sagt er dann würden die
taliban afghanistan in eine bessere
zukunft führen doch gilt das auch für
seine töchter
ich denke dass die taliban mädchen bald
wieder erlauben zur schule zu gehen und
meinungsfreiheit zu lassen ich bin kein
taliban aber ich bin sehr sicher dass
sie die mädchen schulen geschlossen
haben um das schulwesen zu reformieren
es wird so kommen dass alle kinder
wieder zur schule gehen können aber dann
nach geschlechtern getrennt zum beispiel
könnten die jungen vormittags und die
mädchen nachmittags zur schule
sind die taliban tatsächlich zu reformen
fähig bislang haben die neuen machthaber
die leisen hoffnungen darauf enttäuscht
das erleben vor allem afghanistans
frauen denen nahezu alle freiheitsrechte
genommen wurden
wir sind verabredet mit dem
stellvertretenden taliban-sprecher bilal
karimi bevor das interview beginnen kann
müssen wir eine lange debatte führen
denn der taliban-sprecher möchte nicht
mit einer frau im bild zu sehen sein es
ist das erste mal dass ein taliban das
verlangt auch das ein zeichen dafür dass
die angebliche offenheit eher weniger
wird sie können ihr kein interview
machen wo sie mit der kamera reden ich
bin journalistin sie sprechen mit mir
wenn sie nicht mit mir sprechen wollen
okay dann gehen wir
doch der taliban-sprecher will das
interview nicht platzen lassen
wir haben kein problem mit der
anwesenheit dieser frau
wir respektieren sich
ich habe auch kein problem mit ihren
fragen
es ist nur so dass ich mich nicht
besonders wohl fühlen wenn ich mit ihr
zusammen setzen
viele karimi erklärt sich bereit das
interview zu machen solange keine kamera
uns beide in einem bild zeigt
wo steht denn geschrieben das mädchen
oberhalb der sechsten klasse nicht mehr
zur schule dürfen
sie sollten auf dinge die mit dem islam
zu tun haben nicht oberflächlich schauen
das ist ein land das 43 jahre für seine
spirituellen und islamischen werte
gekämpft hat
der taliban-sprecher weicht vielen
meiner fragen aus aber er gibt mir noch
mit frauen seien in seinem land stets
willkommen solange sie sich an die
regeln halten und ich frage mich werden
sich diese regeln in zukunft noch
verschärfen
in nur einem jahr haben die taliban die
wenigen mühsam errungenen fortschritte
der vergangenen 20 jahre zunichte
gemacht für die mehrheit der menschen
hat sich die lage dramatisch
verschlechtert
afghanistan ist sicherer geworden doch
zu welchem preis
die die jahrelang für den terror
verantwortlich waren führen jetzt einem
land in dem menschenrechte und
meinungsfreiheit nicht mehr gelten
ein land in dem minderheiten der willkür
ausgesetzt sind ein land in dem hunger
herrscht und die wirtschaft am boden
liegt
die perspektive für die die afghanistan
wieder aufbauen sollen wird mit jedem
tag schlechter
und so verlassen immer mehr menschen das
land der drachenläufer